[BEEPING SOUNDS]
SPEAKER: Google
Kubernetes Engine
provides a managed environment
for deploying, managing,
and scaling your
containerized applications
using Google infrastructure.
The environment
Kubernetes Engine provides
consists of multiple machines,
specifically, Google Compute
Engine instances
grouped together
to form a container cluster.
Kubernetes draws on the
same design principles
that run popular Google
services and provides
the same benefits--
automatic management
and scaling,
rolling updates, and more.
When you run your applications
on a container cluster,
you're using technology based
on Google's 10-plus years
of experience running production
workloads in containers.
When you run a Kubernetes
engine cluster,
you also gain the benefit of
advanced cluster management
features that Google
Cloud Platform provides.
These include Google Cloud
Platform's load balancing
for Compute Engine
instances, node pools
to designate subsets of
nodes within a cluster
for additional flexibility,
automatic scaling
of your cluster's node instance
count, automatic upgrades
for your cluster's
node software,
node auto-repair to maintain
node health and availability,
logging and monitoring with
Stackdriver for visibility
into your cluster.
This hands-on lab
shows you how to deploy
a containerized application
with Kubernetes Engine.
Next up on our quest
is Container Registry--
Qwik Start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]